Mariah Barnhart and her three-year-old
daughter Dahlia have had a difficult
year Dahlia was diagnosed with an
aggressive form of brain cancer in June
of 2013 they had diagnosed her with an
Ana plastic astrocytoma which is a
higher grade cancer so we were pretty
much confronted early on with the fact
that this was about the worst case
scenario undergoing conventional
treatments such as these surgeries and
chemotherapy are not only very harsh but
if the children do survive they end up
with very long-term pretty horrific side
effects Mariah immersed herself in
research to find any treatment that
could improve dahlias condition she came
across CBD a major component to the
cannabis plant unlike more commonly no
THC CBD is a cannabinoid that is in no
way psychoactive it doesn't get you high
she says that CBD has worked wonders for
Dalia the first night she took it she
slept through the night for the first
time in her entire almost three years of
life she very quickly started to get her
appetite back she was thirsty which for
any critically ill child but
specifically a child on these harsh
chemotherapies hydration and nutrition
are so vitally important to their
well-being mariah is not alone advocates
for cvd argue that the supplement can
help treat all sorts of ailments from
cancer to epilepsy but most people
aren't even aware of its existence mark
thornton is a senior fellow at the
ludwig von mises institute who has
taught at alabama's auburn university he
says prohibition is to blame the war on
drugs increases the risk and the
penalties of being caught and therefore
suppliers have a tendency a strong
desire to bring in highly potent
marijuana and so all of their efforts
are given to driving up the potency of
THC in marijuana and as a consequence
they've also reduced the potency of CBD
that's in part because CBD actually
counteracts the psychoactive effects of
THC making it less desirable for growers
when you talk to people and you say
medical marijuana that doesn't get you
high and has no side effects they're
completely caught off guard because the
CB
d is something that was never talked
about through the 70s 80s 90s and it's
only been since medical marijuana was
legalized in certain places that people
have begun experimenting with different
types of seeds different ways of growing
marijuana general community doesn't know
about us yet Charles vest represents
hempmedspx one of the emerging providers
researching and manufacturing CBD
products we've been growing commercial
hip for about six years and it's been a
long long arduous process to come up
with a strain that is as high as our
strain is and develop it cultivate it
break it down into an island and import
it into the United States bringing CBD
back is a slow process but limited
supply and lack of awareness aren't the
only barriers Mariah says her doctors
wouldn't even discuss CBD I was really
shocked i discussed diets supplements in
the range of dozens of these extracts
and the only thing that could not be
discussed was cannabis extract they're
reluctant to adopt it into their
practices and to prescribe it for their
patients because they could be
implicated under federal drug laws and
shut down and lose their license their
hands are tied they have no choice the
regulatory aspect of CBD is still a
convoluted and and murky area there's
the FDA the FBI the FTC V the DEA goes
on and on though with advocates like
Mariah spreading awareness and the issue
of marijuana legalization being added to
state dockets nationwide Thornton says
there's reason to be optimistic about
CBDs future in medicine once we see
states that were it's legal and it's
used and it's shown to be effective I
think that will spread to other states
as well and we'll get to the full
potential I myself am using this product
for my daughter as a supplement to her
conventional treatment and I've never
felt better about a decision that I've
made in my entire life and I really
really find that it's my responsibility
to inform other
Ernst of that